are you kidding me
I'm sorry I really was back there hiding
a picture I'm so sorry okay oh I mean oh
lordy I might have peed myself just a
tiny bit all right you guys I am super
excited I know somebody out there has
some unnatural love for the person
that's about to come out on this stage
but it can't be SD intense or unnatural
as mine ladies and gentlemen please
welcome to the stage Zack Snyder
okay so first of all this obviously is
not your first comic-con
you're a pro so welcome back to Hall H
and this is a very special movie I want
to know a little bit quickly about how
stoked you are you always been a comic
book enthusiast you've lived in this
world for a while now how insane is this
particular film for you
well it's cool because I mean for me you
know it's really a dream come true type
a project because I've always been into
the sort of big icon superheroes and
Batman and Superman I mean I don't know
after that what do you do yeah it's uh
they're they're pretty is pretty epics
yeah it's it and by the way and getting
a chance to make this particular movie
with with this particular cast it's it I
don't know for me how it gets any any
better than that yeah I really honestly
it's it's been a pleasure and an honor
working with this this group um it's
it's and I've seen some footage of home
was extraordinary I don't I don't know
quite how to articulate what an epic
what an epic collision and story this is
going to be I think the thing to do
right now is to bring the rest of the
cast Alan Alan do it yeah okay so ladies
and gentlemen please welcome to the
stage Holly Hunter
Wonder Woman herself go
Jesse Eisenberg
sinister he's super sinister look at him
he's got a blazer on that's evil
ladies and gentlemen Amy
out of one suit and into another back on
our stage Henry Cavill
and ladies and gentlemen the Batman
hi everybody yes JC um Oh Jeremy do we
not have Jeremy oh he is here he wasn't
he oh well ladies and gentlemen Jeremy
Irons wonderful our team is fully
assembled okay so I think before we chat
there's something that zach wants to
show everybody
oh yeah well alright so um we put this
together especially for you guys it's um
it's uh not not the whole movie of
course but uh I think you get a little
bit of a taste of what it's about
I've got two big questions off the top
before I move to the audience and the
first one is for people here who are not
DC experts not everybody has read every
DC book three people in the back who've
never slept how canonical is this
conflict how rooted in canon is the
Batman V Superman conflict or is this
something that was created for this film
because personally I never heard of it
till now well hey I mean listen you know
the if you want to talk about the story
itself or about the the sort of
particulars of this movie that was the
thing that we it's definitely based on
just ideas that we had you know in a
room talking about like what would be
cool to see now the idea of Batman
fighting Superman is not is not a it's a
it's a thing that happens all the time
in the comic books it's um but you know
for me images like there's a bunch of
images and there's been allowed to talk
about my sort of love of a particular
comic book which is but you know the
Dark Knight Returns which is you know
a comic book that I love and and I I
definetly omage a lot in the movie as a
way of saying to Frank Miller like your
genius and I think that book is genius
but the story itself is not that story
um the story itself is a story that we
came up with just um you know on our own
Chris Terrio
who is the amazing writer of the the
screenplay um you know as a genius who
you work with been on Argo and did an
amazing job and that movie is great and
you know he and he you know he's you
know he and I just you know we just
talked about like what how do you make
this make sense like what is the lie of
Batman fighting Superman in it and
there's a lot of we had a lot of great
we had done stuff in Man of Steel that
actually allowed us to create a conflict
that really makes sense for what this
movies about and it also sort of
launched you toward what could be bigger
conflicts with maybe more more other
superheroes who knows I mean I don't I
mean I do know I totally know you're a
comic tease yeah um oh nice yeah thank
you thank you I'm glad you work through
that with me because my sagas
um this is also the first time we're
seeing Batman and Superman together on
the big screen I've seen it in the books
before obviously many times and it's
also first time we both have we have
both Gotham and metropolis together so
again how did you merge those universes
and kind of what rules did you follow
and what rules did you break yeah well I
mean I think the rule that with the big
rule that we broke is we put Gotham and
metropolis right next to each other I
don't know if it appears that way ever
maybe somewhere probably it's been you
know if you dig deep enough you can find
a justification for just about
everything um but it made sense to us
and work for our story that they were
kind of sister cities you know across a
big bay and so you had kind of it's like
Oakland in San Francisco kind of huh
yeah
I'm from San Francisco San Francisco
would win I think okay so you're from
metropolis I'm from metropolis okay good
that feels good um we look people know
this world and they think they know this
world intimately but there have been so
many iterations and so many reboots
obviously in the DC Universe I want to
talk a little bit about the panel here
because this is a pretty iconic group of
characters that people know that have
been played before if we could just go
down the line and talk a little bit
about what creative challenge that
presents when you're playing a character
that's been played before multiple times
by multiple actors what do you again
what do you stay true to from the Canon
and what do you invent and was that
challenging for you did everybody just
find a new way into the character no
it's simple I don't know should we start
with me uh yeah why we start with call
anyone who would like to start this is a
democracy okay
well Michael Caine was pretty amazing as
Alfred so I had big shoes to sit in but
he's a little different my Alfred so I
think there are surprises in store but I
I carried along myself on the explosions
around me and on the world around me I
followed the boss and tried to make him
happy and tried to make him safe and try
to make him grow up a little uh hi
everyone you look so beautiful thank you
for being here I'm so excited so I'm
just buying some time um well for me
with Wonder Woman I feel like I have
been given such a huge opportunity to
show the strong beautiful side of women
finally and
thank you and Wonder Woman has all the
strength of a superhero but at the same
time at the same time she's very
sophisticated loving and has a lot of
emotional intelligence so for me I feel
very very privileged to be the one who's
gonna bring her back to life and I just
can't wait to celebrate this character
and I hope you all enjoy it did you do
the girl power okay girl power Chris I
was gonna say the thing about the strong
independent women but she took a um dead
uh know my character has been in
obviously other movies and you know
there's always kind of like a can't be
element to the character but probably in
terms of your question I think there's
probably a real kind of emotional
groundedness to this version of it and I
tribute that to the writer Chris Terrio
his exit is just such a phenomenal
writer and gives every character in this
movies like real emotional core even
though the situations are so heightened
and theatrical mm-hmm yes it's also he
had also had the most luxurious locks of
any luthor ever really very I mean swing
that around that was beautiful very low
bar they were all bald it's great I've
never been to comic-con
I just realized and you guys heard you
guys are awesome me a lot of energy I
like it um
Lois Lane uh I wanted to be Lois Lane
since I was five years old so there we
go and I watched I think it was Superman
to on repaid over and over and over
um but when that when the opportunity
arose of course I was nervous I wanted
to you know make you guys all happy with
Lois but at the same time I was just
willing and open to sort of bring a very
modern take on her and and um and and
just sort of embrace again this really
strong woman and and it's it's this
wonderful thing that women have where we
have this emotional intelligence and and
vulnerability along with strength that I
thought was really a beautiful that Zack
lets me bring to Lois um for me
well obviously especially Tresor Eve did
such a fantastic job I was a it was a
dangerous for me to go anywhere near
that so I left that to its own thing and
then just with Zack on Man of Steel
built the character as much as I could
drawing from the Canon and I've just
tried to follow that and stay true to
the character that we we ran with the
Man of Steel
I think if I uh if I thought too hard
about the actors who played this part
before I couldn't have taken the job I
mean Tim Burton Val Kilmer George
Clooney the great Christian Bale and I I
talked to sac about I was like are you
sure you know and he said I had this
vision I have this idea for the guy and
you're perfect for it
what do you mean he's like to get them
end of his rope he's older he's like a
burnout but instrument thank you thanks
mom
yeah the the the truth was that he took
me through the process of creating this
character that I quite almost didn't see
and at the end of it I was like even
sort of astonished to look at and go
that's exactly what you pitched me and I
wasn't even sure I was I was doing it I
had this really weird experience where
before we started the movie I was
getting my kid Halloween costume and my
son is really into Batman and why is Lee
and he we went to a store a costume
store in Los Angeles and it's pretty
empty and I was in the aisle and I heard
this boy and I turn around its Christian
Bale it was the sweetest kind of it and
there he and I are standing in the
Batman comic Batman costume bro and I
said look man you know you're the best
like what do you think you got any tips
and make sure you can piss in that suit
these are practical concerns yeah we put
a zipper on it yeah did you actually I
think Henry we put a zipper on this your
suit retro actively didn't we this time
yeah this time yeah yeah you don't think
of these things it's I think it'd be
fine I mean how long is it gonna be a
don't give you that long yeah like 15
hours though oh and also are you saying
let me just say Holly uh has an original
part in the film and I've been such a
giant fan of Holly's forever when we
were writing the script back yeah I was
like okay we need to find a pup I need
we need to write a part for Holly Hunter
to play in this movie I don't care what
the f it is yeah but it turns out that
it's in a super important part so that's
that's just that's good but she's
amazing so I got a fan um I'm gonna I'm
gonna do that I'm gonna be I'm gonna be
a dick
ah because you know the the title begs a
very specific question right which part
of the title uh the Batman V Superman
part of your title very good uh and you
know you've heard this a million times
since you started developing this film
and you'll hear a million times after
who would win a fight between Batman and
Superman now I'm not gonna ask that
question because I don't know if I made
a whole movie about yeah that's good so
we can just answer today and then you
know um because again essential to this
conflict is an amour you know an
immortal man you know a God as you
articulated in the film versus a human
being which begs a lot of other
questions about kind of you know
embracing our own humanity and what that
means
however this Batman seems to be mecha
Batman he is a little bit of an
Augmented Batman I think the thing to
look at in the we call it the mech suit
whatever but it really in truth it's not
it's a self-preservation concept not to
you know give anything away but it's not
really enhancing his strength more than
protecting him buying him time if you
will from everything that Superman is
going to get a lot of his eyeballs
almost like a pinata
you know so it's it's a race you have to
see because it's slightly complicated
okay
we're gonna edit the whole movie the
whole entire handle that question
literally that's the only question all
right we're gonna take an audience
question uh yeah hi um okay so uh haha
you're adorable
look at you yes thank you strike a pose
don't anyway clearly in the movie you do
with a lot of philosophical issue who's
in the film and what I was wondering is
if any of what you walk through maybe
perhaps changed the way that you will
look at life now you just stayed
adorable through the entire question
who's it for
pure adorability who is that much
smarter than everyone up here whoever
has an answer for it
bucket of cute on the Left sack you can
take this one
is there anybody wants to tackle that I
was like those guys down at that end
that seems like that man Superman I just
I don't know it's kind of tough for me
to say I play a god so I'm gonna step
away from this I think there are some
really interesting that Zach and Chris
put together some really interesting
ideas of you know metropolis being a big
successful city in Gotham City being a
place where a lot more downtrodden
people live and there's a fairy they
take across the people who work in
Metropolis take from Gotham City and the
whole idea of you know wealth and power
and the way power and genders fear and
there were a lot of really ideas that
were a little bit too smart for me to
understand but that the movie was
trafficking in and that I thought made
it feel real to me and and smart and so
I was even more proud to be part of it
this is from someone who made a movie
that I had to I had to go to Wikipedia
every five minutes to understand Argo
but sure yeah Superman vs Batman too
smart for Ben Affleck okay
sure I'll get more Wikipedia yeah when
we're all Superman's back out of the gym
again Oh was it leg day or arm day all
right let's go to look at this guy's
look at this guy's tattoos yeah he's got
tattoos on his cows oh very duper man ah
how do I know that I've seen him before
you know what back so have we go for it
buddy when you guys were filming the
movie at what point in time did you say
oh my god we're coming up with something
great awesome we're gonna blow all your
God says minds away without spoilers but
if you do or spoiler please thank you
while shooting the movie I feel like yes
I mean you know like the truth is I mean
when you're shooting a movie there are
moments when you shoot the movie that
feel like wow this is cool I mean just
for instance when actually when we were
doing a look we did a little photo shoot
um you know while everyone's getting
their costumes together and it's like
Wonder Woman and Superman and Batman all
sort of standing there getting the
pictures taken you're like oh my lord
that's crazy
okay but I think that you know for me
was it actually happens long before that
you know when we're just kind of
figuring out what we're gonna do and I'm
drawing and we're just kind of getting
ideas of you know different kind of
images that we're going to create and I
just normally this is gonna sound weird
but I'm by myself when that's happening
um and I don't do anything weird sure
but it is there is that moment like when
you do like if you do a doodle and
you're like oh my lord I know that
that's I want to see that i wanna i want
to let's wear the cameras we need to get
where is everybody come on let's go
shoot this so i think that that's really
for me the moment I don't know like for
these guys if they had different
experiences of course they probably
would but you know because by the time
also I'm filming I've seen the costume a
thousand times and you know it's it's
like a love scene you know there was
everyone talks about oh when you do a
love scene is it sexy and I I don't know
because I've never done love scene in a
movie I've only witnessed it um that
would be weird not good but thank you
know hey we say the actors are always
like yeah no it's like this is
so I don't know if they have that same
feeling when they're in their superhero
costumes I had a feeling where you know
I am
first of all wants a Christian Bale's
also buying his son a suit he doesn't
just hang out but for me you know like
you look at the cast and you look at the
script and that's so much of what's
there and I always thought you can only
tweak a certain amount past that because
you've almost kind of made the movie and
I remember a day about two weeks in it
where I read the scene and I thought
about how to play it and I came in and
watched it and I thought okay yeah we
should probably like shoot it this way
or that way and Zach set the shot up so
that it was one shot and he put it on a
crane and it came around and it covered
everybody's dialogue and it kind of
encompassed the scope of what we want to
do and I was just like [ __ ] I would
never do that that's so good
sorry it says people are under 18 um
they've heard it before but anyway
that's I remember thinking that we were
in good hands ya know kind words from a
guy man um before we before we move
towards the end we just haven't heard
anything from Holly and I just want to
hear something out of your beautiful
mouth with your beautiful voice I just
that's it thank you all right well we
have one we have one last what kind of a
thing you want to do for the audience
before we go and are we gonna take
another oh sure yeah guys I guess we
should take one more look at the piece
cuz I know it's it goes by fast guys
this happened to all of us today as a
team wrap it up in a warm little ball
stick it deep inside this has been
amazing Batman vs Superman dawn of
Justice opens March 25th 2016 please
give it up for Holly Hunter Jeremy Irons
gold Edo Jesse Eisenberg Amy Adam
Henry Cavill Ben Affleck and your
fearless leader mr. Zack Snyder go and
kick ass happy Cohn
ah
you